all right so the official title for this
is automated performance budgeting into
your pipeline with sites Biao it's kind
of a mouthful and also I put w / there
for some horrible reason so apologies
about that and I just want to do I
normally don't do public speaking very
happy that we have the HB track for
those who are beginners and/or yeah and
I just really wanted to share this tool
because I think it's awesome I think it
really doesn't get enough credit and
it's been around for an extremely long
time and I just wanted to share it with
you so that's what I'll be doing here
today so quick overview so we're gonna
talk about my own personal performance
journey some I guess just like
performance budgets in general what they
are what they're for and we're going to
talk about sites video specifically and
performers budgets within sites video
specifically we're going to talk about
there's a lot of different tools that do
performance budgeting sites video is one
of them and there's a lot of other
really amazing tools that I found with
in my journey so yeah we'll be talking
about other tools and things to consider
and I wanted to throw out some stuff
that I've been experimenting with and
what I see as my future for front-end
performance what I'd like to see and
what I've experimented with so first a
little bit about me there's me behind my
pizza curtains that I sewed myself and
put up in my office and some things that
I like I go by the name of debug XYZ on
the interweb
and that's because I have way too many
hobbies for my own good
I'm not good at any of them so this list
here is all things I'm really bad at so
I'm into growing the Queen peppers tech
minimalism was tech minimalism is hard
growing Queen peppers is hard
accessibility is hard skateboarding was
really hard turns ableism is insane I am
horrible horrible at that one but I love
learning about it
Fernan engineering is insanely hard
right now I'm into learning NYX OS which
is this operating system that is
configuration is code and I've been
doing like I don't want to say how long
I've been taking front-end seriously but
I'm relearning CSS and spending
investing a lot of time in that as well
so here's I'm going to quickly go
through two of my hobbies don't worry
I'm not going to go through my full list
of hobbies so one of the things that I
got into one of my brother's gave me
chilli between big I don't know how to
say it between pepper seeds and he's
such suggested I give it a shot they
have a 15 percent germination rate the
normally birds only eat them and they
kind of eat away the whole of the seed
so you kind of have to emulate that to
make sure that they're happy and keep
them hot Thrasher so this is a 90s 90s
thing I'll see if I can resize my slide
here there we go
yeah here we have the pose of the year
so at this point I had been
skateboarding for a very long time I had
it was an absolute obsession of mine
it takes tons of practice and and is is
difficult
and so when I was skateboarding I would
I would go all around downtown
I grind the you know just destroy the
curbs at my local library and it get
really hot and a veces boost of
assessment Ostara heed a la biblioteca
para err FS co e who God con la compo a
veces vivos tava jihad impress ganas de
código a la casa para estudiar when I
would get really really hot and
exhausted from skateboarding I would go
into my local library and and cool off
and play with the computer and that's
where I actually learned to code and I
would print out printout actually
JavaScript even though I gave up really
quickly and take it home for studying
and I did that because it was hard so
when I knew I was gonna be a programmer
I decided I'd go to boot camp
it was hard so this is me at my
graduation photo in Parris Island and
there's my father and mother supporting
me and my graduation
it was hard front end is hard it's very
difficult and achieving web performance
can be very difficult it's a discipline
within it's like front-end web
performance as a discipline within
front-end and maintaining web
performance is even more difficult you
can really work really hard you know
getting your site to get that time to
first interactive super low
but at the pace that we jump from job to
job and from project to project you're
gonna have a lot of people from with
varying skill levels and and everyone
within front end performance has their
specialties there's amazing foreign
developers who are super knowledgeable
about accessibility but may not know
about Furnham performance so it's
important to share your skill set with
your peers and make sure that you're
having front-end discipline meetings to
kind of share your expertise within the
field so you have to do all of the
things for front-end performance capture
metrics observe trends provide alerting
fixing actual issues on the on the
website because that's what you know I
what we're talking about here is it's
the kind of context that I come in
from is the web and front-end
development so fixing issues on the
website raising awareness with your
peers you know you may you may go
through the same struggle if you're
working on things like security
maintainability maybe you're super into
toss saying you've got to make sure that
you're raising awareness with your peers
as well as consulting you know tools
analysis for analysis providing
supporting platforms one of the first
things I did when I started really
focusing on front-end performance within
my organization was I just started
capturing PageSpeed insights data
because I thought that was really
important for well for reasons that I'll
talk about later and just all of the
things you have to do and it's and it's
pretty intense you know especially if if
you're a smaller shop and and you may
have all of this within your
organization but you still need to
provide that consulting to your peers to
make sure they're aware of the tooling
and infrastructure that's their
performance is critical on the web I'm
not going to talk too much about this
but CPUs are getting really fast we have
using fast mobile devices but you know
not everyone has that and most of the
cell phone adoption right now is
happening from with like new people
buying cell phones who haven't had cell
phones before are low are buying low to
medium tier devices so it is super
important
going in the future and as the web
advance is expectations are getting
higher people are wanting more snappy
experiences users get frustrated they
tend to abandon they tend to be lice
like less likely to come back and nobody
likes a slow site this is this is us
today III actually like I think this is
funny and stuff but like I literally do
this
I literally you know do this to my salad
like it's really gross so yeah most of
you are probably concerned about profit
on your websites
this is it so step 1 step 2 performance
profit check it out no seriously there's
amazing resources by Google and there's
this book that I read called time is
money the business value of web
performance that if you're trying to
sell web performance to your
organization you you gotta read this
book it's amazing it gave me tons of
case studies to show to my leadership
and you know the you know you could
don't do an a/b test for it look to
other studies seriously because it's
very difficult I don't recommend it and
you're ignoring a key part of the
equation there's a lot to it it's very
complex but you know SEO is a big factor
to revenue so where you're you know
with Google having tools like lighthouse
and PageSpeed insights being directly
factored into your PageRank score this
one of the like key pieces of advice
that you know Google lets you know that
is is a big impact so I forgot some
things in that big list of all the
things and that's a regression so it's
it's easy to accidentally you know you
have our project where you need to
convert a time zone so you pull in
moments and then you realize that you
need a moment time zone plug-in and then
that pulls in literally all of the
geographical latitude and longitude
information about the time zone lines
that you didn't know about and wasn't
documented so it can be an easy mistake
to make and and you need tools to
support you throughout that and also
it's a it's a it's about scalability as
well it's kind of a weird term to use in
the sense but I think about
organizational scalability you can't be
there for everything as you know maybe
that one or maybe there's a couple
performance experts and you have this
large organization or a large project so
I tend to speak within the context of
organizations but you may be working on
an open-source project where performance
is absolutely critical it may be for
mobile web and I'm still probably
forgetting tons of things so what it
what our performance budgets it's it's
is what it sounds like you define
something like a budget JSON you can
specify some things too typically you
might want to fail your build it's a bit
of a touchy subject to roll out to your
organization but I'll talk a little bit
about that later
how can performance budgets help first
of all it gets the conversation started
when you introduce performance budgets
into your organization or a project
you're immediately going to start
talking about performance which is
immediate win but what's more important
one of the keys to performance budgeting
is it keeps the conversation going so
this is you know when you're introducing
a new feature and then you you roll it
out and then it fails the build and
you're like oh well lesson learned I'm
gonna make sure that I bring up this
conversation station a little bit early
because it kind of pushed our project a
little bit out you're making explicit
trade-offs instead of implicitly kind of
making that trade-off you're being
direct and and more like you're being
more direct about it this has been a
conversation there has been a commit
maybe you even bump your budget that's
okay it works like that in the real life
if you've ever tried budgeting and like
going on a hardcore budget the first
thing you do is over over but over
restrict yourself and you adjust and
that's okay
but is being explicit about it that kind
of helps out with the situation and it
prevents accidents this is one of the
biggest things for me so there's a lot
of different things that you can budget
on
so there's score base metrics if you're
using something like lighthouse you
might be familiar with gives you an
overall performance score so you can
assert on that so if your SEO is
critical to your organization and you
need that traffic coming in to make your
revenue you know that that score is
going to be important so your SEO team
might even demand that and then there's
quantitative so this is about numbers
it's about how many kilobytes of
JavaScript do we think we really need
and kind of asserting against that it
can be how many images you have on your
home page and maybe it'll remind you
that oh I need to look lazy load that's
that's one of the things that like I do
as like consulting within my
organization lazy load lazy lazy
so timings as well so the timings can be
difficult in fact this is one of the
things that I really wanted to touch on
because when you roll out performance
budgets into your organization the last
thing you want is false positives
especially at the beginning so that's
one of the key advices pieces of advice
that I have is to make sure that if
you're budgeting make sure that your
timings are that what you're budgeting
on doesn't have false positives and that
your timings are are stable before I
forget you know because this is this is
a important part I have some advice on
keeping your timing stable so within the
type of websites that I work on there's
lots of third parties and that can cause
a lot of volatility in your metrics so
you don't want to include that within
the metrics that you're budgeting on it
is important that you keep an eye on
those things but make it separate and
budget for them separately accessibility
budgets this is about performance
budgeting but it's an easy thing to do
so don't forget to check the accessible
accessibility box within your
performance budgeting tool a lot of them
come with that so you can assert against
that and it's and it's an easy win for
accessibility just a caveat here
automated accessibility detection only
and catches like an extremely small
amount of actual accessibility issues
I've seen percentages as low as like
three percent but that doesn't mean that
you can't take advantage of some of
those easy wins of making some simple
mistakes so don't forget to check the
checkbox and four and don't forget to
use your late
tags so back to performance how do you
roll out performance budgets within your
organization
I mentioned that it can be easy to be
too aggressive and it can be difficult
to to sell it one of my main pieces of
advice is when you when it comes to role
you know in your organization is to
don't immediately jump which is a
slowest item on your page go to the
fastest because really this is about
regression and keeping a conversation
going and I'd recommend if you have a
fast area already do that first let's
see here yeah you really have to get
everyone on board so that that's
actually why I'm here this is my sprint
demo so yeah you have you know I'm gonna
be given this presentation to my
organization as well
another thing you know make sure you
plant those seeds early so I've been
talking about this for a long time
within my organization and people are
asking me for it now and that's that's a
wonderful thing some places to focus
places you know areas that are really
fast new projects can be a great place
to start just for like my contacts the
the happy past is a great place to focus
this is the areas your website that the
users are going to be kind of jumping
through some ideas of things that you
can budget on so things like time to
interactive speed index is an amazing
visual metric and I was exposed to that
by another insanely wonderful tool
webpagetest
it's you know people kind of look at it
all weird but it's
is really an incredible project and yeah
just want to mention that tool now
bundle size basically anything within
the performance API so like with size
video specifically it has an incredible
amount of metrics we'll talk about it a
little bit more you can even write your
own performance budget metrics size pedo
is very pluggable it's been that way for
a while and yeah you can you know I want
this checkout button to display within
this amount of seconds it's pretty
awesome how do you figure out what your
budget is I think at Google i/o 2019
I'll be they mentioned they think they
released the perform performance budget
I Oh website which is a great tool to
kind of gauge you can you kind of use a
slider to kind of ask me you know how
fast you want your page to load and then
slide like how many kilobytes of
JavaScript and and whatnot so that's an
amazing introduction of a nice little
tool analyze your competitors there's
you know you can actually there's a
little SEO trick to find your
competitors I actually don't remember I
don't know I imagine it but yeah you
know just look at your competitors see
how they're doing this is another thing
is that when you're working against
competitors you want you know just a
slight difference between your
competitor doesn't really make that huge
of an impact you've got to be way faster
than your competitor for to actually
notice this there's statistics on this
and studies on this what happens when
you make a mistake what happens when
your budget fails in your pipeline you
can you know obviously optimize the
feature that you're introducing you can
remove other features you can redesign
the feature you may
even catch this early as you're you know
talking about it early in the design
development process but it can just as
easily be redesigned afterwards or just
don't do the feature at all it's an
option bless is more seriously it's so
easy to forget so here's a screenshot of
the site's video budgeting results I
don't think I'm gonna have enough time
to do you know an end up demo but the
integration within Jenkins is pretty
awesome there's documentation on how to
integrate that the documentation on site
Sparrow is incredible and yeah we'll
talk a little bit more about sites video
has something called coach this is the
thing that gives you advice it has a
philosophy of trying not to give you any
bad advice if you follow the coach you
will win browser time is the thing that
kind of actually opens up the web page
and and tries to capture measurements
it's actually very cool technically if
you deep dive into it uses thing called
X v FB x virtual frame buffer its X
server display it's like an X display
server which is super cool it uses the
neat protocol I like to dig into that
more and dig into site speedo even more
it has this tool called page X ray also
shout-out to the designer who
contributed to Sykes we these are all
little icons that someone worked on for
the project and I'm just using them in
my slides so there's this page X ray
which is really just kind of a format
that allows different pieces with
insights video to kind of understand
what's going on it's you
on the compared site speed AO which is a
waterfall comparison tool
that's an amazing is amazing work like
this this I just loved this project this
and yeah I definitely want to deep dive
into that at some point here's an
example of some of the the format here
it's kind of neat you can this is where
you you would if you wrote your own
plugin you can add additional
information let's see so compare dot
size video definitely check out that the
the waterfall comparison I'm obsessed
with waterfall comparisons will actually
I'll have to jump through some of these
slides because I want to talk about the
future here especially when it comes to
waterfall comparisons I really love size
video because it kind of just kind of
fell within the technologies that I use
at work so we use graphite in graph
wanna they've end out graph graphite in
graph wanna JSON which again just
directly import to have insanely nice
displays of all of your metrics if
you're using sites video not just for
budgeting but for tracking metrics
separately the you know there's this
there's this cool thing called a
throttle I was reading a tiny I haven't
deep dive into it but there's there's
some really interesting stuff about this
a lot of the volatility again like
volatility within your timing metrics is
critical there's this kind of network
replay thing that is an experimental
right now that it would capture what
during the task what your network
activity was and that replay that
activity so that stabilizes your metrics
but this is pretty insane idea
and so throttle is inspired by the
funniest github project name I've ever
heard in my life it's called so we're
talking about a tool that slows down
your website it's called Comcast
[Applause]
it's just incredible
jockeying lycée read the manual because
the documentation is insanely good
there's tons of integration and
instructions for I've implemented it
using my own personal gitlab instance
and it wasn't too bad
I didn't read the manual don't recommend
not reading the manual I kind of did it
on my own and yeah in and I also
integrated for work on chickens instance
there's taught you know these are
documented integrations for github
actions jenkins travis circle CI get lab
the concepts are you know basically the
same across platforms but difficulty
varies for meeting setting it up on
jenkins was difficult because work we
use just a plug for our blog our DevOps
engineers are amazing so engineering
dari i.com they write a lot about
infrastructure is code there and so I
had to deep dive into Jenkins DSL which
is a you know little subset of groovy in
order to implement these this pipeline
integration as infrastructure as code so
it seemed hard so I gave it a shot and
you know I don't expect you to be able
to read this and I wish I could pull it
up a little bit more but yeah this is
what Jenkins DSL looks like yes I
specified what I recommend if you're
rolling this out to a large organization
is to provide some default sane and
generous budgets and so that's what I
tried to do but you want to have that
flexibility so your different teams who
have different requirements and
different needs can override those
budgets so that's what I did here so I
pulled in some default budgets merge it
with the project budget and then
did an assertion which basically just
ran sites video as a doctor image and
then I let bit we use bitbucket know
about that and the Jenkins integration
is awesome because it uses the HTML
publisher plug-in which sites pedo will
output like a full-blown website with a
video showing the page load illustrating
the visual metrics and all for when your
build fails it you know you can output
some tax that will link you to a nice
little you know whole suite of HTML that
you can kind of view and kind of figure
out what's going on with your budget
yeah good love should be pretty
straightforward follow ducts there's
lots of other budgeting tools and lots
of amazing you know absolutely
incredible tools so I've one thing that
you can forget is that web pack actually
has performance budgeting built-in you
just may not know it so when you see
that your job you know if you're want to
roll out performance you know some sort
of basic performance budgeting and to
your organization you can there's a flag
with an web pack that you can flip to
make sure that it fails if your bundle
size is over you know some insane amount
so you can make that assertion there
lighthouse is obviously amazing it has
sites video actually has lighthouse
integration so you can use sites video
to run lighthouse and assert against
lighthouse scores as well as assert
against other lighthouse metrics but
lighthouse is a great place to get
started it's a you know if you're at all
care about SEO which a lot of people do
late house is definitely into the thing
to look at speed curve I've experimented
with this it's incredible as well and
the future so I think regression
analysis is
it's kind of empty I maybe I just don't
know much about the tool sets here but
I've done some basic experimentation
we've set up a private web page test
instance within our organization where
we have real devices that we can run
tests against and I just ran a job that
ran web page tasks private instance on
real mobile devices and started plotting
that information out on a graph using d3
and then what was I haven't seen done
before and this may exist is you know
you see the graph go up but okay what
what happened why so what we did you
just you'd select the low point of the
the item that was ran by webpagetest
and you select the high point and that
took you to the wonderful waterfall
comparison tool where I've caught
seriously so many issues well we had
this you know experimental prototype ah
it's you know the ease of being will
observe regressions is is important
within my own personal journey setting
up web page test is is is not
straightforward and especially with
physical devices and I think it could be
easier if if tools like webpage tests
and other tools could could start using
the cloud so there's a lot of cloud
services that are providing device forms
and if these tools can start integrating
with those device forms instead of
plugging in your real phones you can
start using services like G cloud or AWS
device farm to connect and run your
tests but right now these these are
mostly focused around
app you know actual mobile app tests so
I don't really you know I have a lot to
learn here but I don't really see a
straightforward way to kind of run those
tests in the browser and integrate it
when the tools I've spent a ton of time
kind of doing research
here's a couple of links and the Google
i/o talk is basically the same as this I
highly recommend checking that out
there's Google has put out so many
amazing tools and guides and guidance so
I'll actually flesh out publish these
slides and put even more links and
credits here that's my talk thing thank
you everyone
I appreciate it
[Applause]
[Music]